so the first talk will be by eating fung
and is on uh batching and optimal
multi-stage bipartite allocations
and um eating you can get started okay
thank you matt
so today i'm happy to talk about my
joint workplace wrap from
chicago
so this project is basically motivated
by the real world application
in the online market where the platform
needs to dynamically
match the demand request to the supply
and within all this application
different applications have different
allowance for the latency
in other words the longest waiting time
or demand request can wait
before it has to be responded
and in the application which allows some
of the latency the platform can make the
more efficient matching decision
by using the batching strategy
specifically
it will rule the demand request together
with
in batches and then makes the stage-wise
matching decision
one for each batch it's easy to imagine
that
in this new paradigm where the platform
using the batching strategy
the matching efficiency will be improved
so a question could be asked here is
that
can we theoretically measure this
efficiency improvement
by using a smashing strategy
and to do so we need a theoretical model
for this one and before that let's first
revisit the classic model of
online product allocation so in online
allocation there are different
variations for example
online background matching online by
preparation packing
and some other variation so in today's
talk
we will mainly focus on the vertex
weight b matching and say how can we
modify it
to capture our new paradigm where the
platform can use a
batching strategy so in an instance of
vertex with b
matching it will be given as a bipartite
graph
where on one side will have a supply
node which will be given
in an offline fashion where every supply
node will have a heterogeneous weight
as well as a capacity which captures
the total number of demand requests it
can be matched with
and on the other side we'll have a
demand loss which will arrive
to the algorithm near online fashion and
once the models are right
the matching algorithm needs to make the
matching decision for that node
immediately and in this talk we will
mainly focus on how to modify this model
to capture on in our new paradigm and
additionally
we will assume that the matching
algorithm can produce the fractional
solution
and we will assume that all capacity on
the
supply nodes were equals to one
cool so so far the model assumes that
the demand modes
will arrive one by one in your online
fashion
and in our new paradigm we will assume
that they will arrive in batches
specifically suppose we are fixed as
there will be k stage
and there therefore a new a new batch of
demands will arrive in each stage
and for example here is the instance of
two stage
and therefore we have two batches and
another instance
of four stage and therefore we have four
batches
and in our model we do not have any
assumption about
how many so the number of demons within
each batch
cool now let me formally define the
class of match algorithm we are
considering
so once the batch are right the matching
algorithm will observe
the demand vertices within this patch as
well as well as the incident edges
and then this algorithm will need to
make a relocal matching decision
which will be will be a fractional map
which will be a fraction
matching between those demand vertices
and the supply nodes
and and here the yj corresponds to the
current consumption of this
diagram in other words it will be the
fractional degree
has been matched in the previous stage
and our goal is to maximizing the weight
of the matching and we are competing
with a hindsight solution
in other words optimal offline
and in this paper we'll try to identify
the optimal competitive ratio
if i fix the number of stage capital k
and let me remind you that if capital k
equals to 1 we will only have a single
batch
so this will correspond to the fully
offline problem and therefore we know
gamma 1
where equals to 1. and then another
extreme
where every batch contains a single
demand vertices
this will correspond to a fully online
problem
and in this paper our formal research
question is that in the middle
region where we have capital k batch can
we identify the optimal capacity ratio
and even though our model assumes that
the models
are ripe in batches but we can always
pretend that
they are actually arrived in an online
fashion and therefore
the literature from the online
allocation with vertex arrival
to us 3d allocation will always be half
competitive
and balanced algorithm will be 1 minus
already competitive
and in this paper why identify the
optimal comparison
if i fix the number of stage chain and
let me remind you that this gamma k will
be between one minus one re
and one for two stage it will be three
over four
and for three stage it will be 90 over
27
and as capital k goes to infinite it
will convert
to one mass formally and we also show
the same results hold
for other variation of this model for
both fractional solution
and integral solution with large object
assumption
now let me let me give you some taste of
our technique
towards these results so in this paper
we introduced the so-called
polynomial recognized comments
programming measure and
it will contain three steps so in the
first step
we will try to identify a sequence of
polynomial with decreasing degrees
one for each batch and once up and once
a better write
we will try to write down a regularized
max weight matching commerce program
where in the objective function we will
use the those polynomial when
identifying the first layer
as a regularizer and the solution of
this convex program
will be a fractional solution we assign
at that stage
and at the end to show that this
algorithm obtains optimal competitive
ratio
we will consider the ktt condition of
this convex program
and this pkt condition will induce a
graph decomposition
which we will use to build up a primal
dual analysis
and specifically in the for the dual
assignment we construct in those
analysis
we'll be using the property of our graph
decomposition
in other words they will be inspired by
the quantity condition of our convex
program
and in this sense the comics program we
study in this paper
provide a new interpretation for the
classic primal dual analysis
in the classic online application with
vertex arrival
specifically for the dual assignments in
those analysis
it can be solved as a consequence of the
kkt condition
of our convex program with some specific
regularizer
and for example as a balanced algorithm
which
obtains one minus one minus one by the
approximation its dual assignment
can be thought as using our combat
program and instead of using the
radializer also using the polynomial but
using the exponential function as a
regularizer
and that's all of my talk so if you have
any question
uh please feel free to ask questions and
you can also
connect me through my email thank you
thanks eating um so we can take
one quick question if someone has one
while uh clay
clay if you want to start sharing your
screen
and if there's not one from the audience
eating can i quickly ask
um you mentioned that for the integral
setting
you needed a large budget assumption do
you
believe that that's because you would
need a more complicated algorithm to
work with a budget of one or you believe
that the algorithm or you believe that
there may be a stronger impossibility
result
yes i think this is a very good question
so
uh so first so the large part assumption
the standard assumption for the this
kind of online
matching literature and so and on the
other side we also conjecture that
the same competitive ratio can be
achieved for the integral setting with
capacity goes to one but certainly if
our current algorithm does not work
and we need to think about if there are
some other ideas
cool all right thank you very much and
we'll move on
um to the next speaker who is um clayton
thomas
who will tell us about a tiered random
matching markets
thanks matt and this is based on joint
work with atayashi mark braverman
amin siberi and gong jiao
so this is a paper about the stable
matching problem
by a standard analogy this is seeking to
match n
men to n women when each agent has
preferences over all of the agents on
the other side of the market
and our goal is stability and this is
the property
that once i output this one-to-one
matching nobody wants to get up from
their assigned partner
and match with each other instead this
is used
heavily studied in theory and used in
practice
and it's been argued to be really
crucial to prevent market unraveling i
can tell agents when i give them this
matching
why would you want to deviate from the
matching nobody would want to do that
with you
and it's used to match students to
schools and residents to hospitals
as well as other things the most
common matching to use is the one side
optimal matching which can always be
found by the deferred acceptance or
gail shapley algorithm as a reminder
this proceeds by the men
proposing down their preference lists
from their favorite to their least
favorite
and the women tentatively accept the
best proposal reject all others and they
continue making these proposals
to study these markets you kind of need
to put
distributions on the preferences of the
agents
this really gives a lot of valuable
insights that you'd miss by just doing
deterministic studies and to give us a
baseline one of these insights is that
with in men and women and uniformly
random
complete preferences over the other side
the men
are at a very large advantage they get
their login
favorite woman in expectation
where women get much higher much further
down their lists
and divided by login we call this
place that the agents get
the rank that they achieve
and a long line of work has
extended this analysis and found a
variety of different interesting models
that show that different market
parameters can have profound influences
on these ranks
and that a lot of interesting things
happen
but up until now not much has been known
at least not in detail for cases where
the agents are non-uniform
most of the tools were really
specialized to this
indistinguishable agent's case so in
this work we want to give agents
some a priori quality before the market
starts there are some good
and some bad agents that are less
desirable
and what we'll be interested in is these
rank statistics how much
agents like their matches and we'll be
interested in who ends up matched to who
so the distribution we study over
preferences is a tiered
matching market this has a constant
number of
tiers for the men and for the women with
a constant fraction belonging to each
tier
and there's these constant public scores
or you can think of it as the weight
that the agents have
attached to each tier if this is a
residence matching to hospitals example
maybe the tiers on the
residents are the a students for medical
school the b
students etc and the way preferences are
drawn
is from favorite to least favorite
by sampling proportional to the score of
the agents on the other side
so for one example a woman w
is the favorite of a of each man
with probability her score divided by
the sum
of all of the scores of the women and
for one more example
if w1 and w2 have scored 9 and 1
then 90 of men will rank w1 above w-2
we think this is a really natural next
step beyond
uniform markets in fact it's a special
case of
a pretty well studied set of preferences
called popularity preferences which
think of these scores as the popularity
of the agents
the only additional structure we have is
is these tiers big blocks of agents
with the same score
but the key assumptions that the
analysis uses are that the preferences
are identically distributed for each man
and that these weights are constant and
there's only
constant variation in quality
okay so diving into the results for the
purposes of this talk i'll
phrase the results where only the women
are in the tears and then when only the
men are in tears
so these expressions end up giving the
the rank that agents
on both sides of the market end up
achieving
the first thing we can notice is that up
to constant factors
this matches the uniform setting
but the total number of proposals has
increased by this factor
which depends on the smallest public
score on the women's side
alpha min this factor is the ratio of
the average score
this dot product of the score fractions
and
the weights
and this is pretty natural because the
bottom tier of women
is a real bottleneck in this market men
don't want to
match there and so they'll keep making
proposals until finally that bottom tier
is
sort of matched
for women the higher your score is the
lower your rank
is and this is in fact directly
inversely proportional to the score
this makes sense better agents get
better matches
and something really interesting to note
is that the distribution
or the the tier proportions just
factor out they don't end up mattering
for the women
they can sort of just think about their
absolute quality above some baseline
alpha min
when the men are organized into tears
the ranks end up being given by this
expression
these are all uh in expectation and
again this matches the uniform market
up to constants and again ranks are
inversely proportional to score but here
men have to worry about a little more
they their tier set up the tier
fractions delta do factor into their
type
and they sort of have to worry about the
ratio of their score to the average or
more precisely the ratio of their
inverse score
proving that these men's ranks is
inversely proportional to
their score ends up being like the
technical crux of our paper
so just for some very brief intuition
the reason it comes out of the model
is that sort it's sort of the case that
increasing
your score directly corresponds to
increasing
the probability that your proposals are
accepted
and thus inversely corresponds to the
number of proposals you need to make
throughout the
matching market it turns out that
when you put agents on both sides um
these
results still work together and both men
and women make a number of
proposals which is proportional to their
score
and this ends up having a really
interesting consequence on what we call
the distribution of match
types this is the expected fraction of
matches
in the in in the output which are
between tier j of men
and tier i of women and we consider this
for each eye and each j
it ends up being the case that these
fractions match what you would see
from a uniformly random matching up to
lower order terms
and this indicates that there's no
sorting in this market
and instead agents have to settle for
things they
idiosyncratically like and not things
they like because of the tier structure
high types don't necessarily get high
types and just for a super short sketch
of why this happens
in this market with just two equal sized
tiers of scores
two and one each woman receives twice as
many proposals from the low tier men
but she weights the proposals from the
high tier men twice as much
so in the end it's 50 50 whether her
favorite is from the high tier or the
low tier
so for future directions we would like
to extend the model
say to private scores instead of public
scores
um things get a little more interesting
when there are a lot more agents on one
side and we think a lot of these
uh techniques or intuitions can be
applied to mechanism design but that's
of course
for future work all right thanks
thank you um so i think we fell a teeny
bit behind time so maybe can um head
yeah
um share your screen and um if you have
questions for clay we have
the long period after all the talks are
done or you can ask in the q
a right now
all right and
the next talk will be um on randomness
and fairness and two-sided matchings
and it'll be given by hedya behaki
thanks matt uh this is the joint work
with eva tardis
so in this paper we study matching
markets where both sides of the nitrogen
have limitations
on the one side we have the applicants
that although find a lot of the job
positions on the other side desirable
they can only apply to a limited number
of them this may be because the system
has imposed this limit or because
preparing the applications is time
consuming and costly
on the other side we have the job
positions that need to run an interview
process before hiring their applicants
and they can only interview a limited
number of their applicants our goal in
this paper is to study the effect of
these limitations on the matching
and more particularly the size of
dimension
traditionally the matching algorithms
did not take these limitations into
consideration
for example the deferred acceptance
algorithm by dalen shapley assumes that
the participants can consider as many
options as they want
in the more recent years there have been
more work on matching world limitations
but as you see there is still very few
studies on limitations on both sides
let me define our model more formally we
have n applicants and n positions we
show the applicants by circles and the
positions by squares
we focus on the case that the
preferences um
come independently from uniform
distribution that clay also
mentioned in his talk um so this
simple case lets us make our analysis
more tactical
and also we see interesting facts even
in the sample case
we run a three-stage matching mechanism
in the first stage each applicant
applies to k positions
here k equals two so each applicant is
applying to two positions
right next to each position we show the
applications they have received
in the second stage the positions accept
k
prime of their applications for
interview and reject the rest
here k prime is also equal to two the
positions are accepting
um two of their applications and uh
rejecting
the rest immediately after they run the
interviews and refine their preferences
we want the applicant proposing deferred
acceptance algorithm
and finally we consider a large market
setting
meaning that we study the market when k
and k prime
the limits are constant while n
approaches infinity
and the main problem we focus on from
here on is to find the expected size of
the matching or fraction of matched
participants
as a function of k and k prime the limit
on the number of
applications and interviews
okay so let's start with the case where
the limit on the number of interviews is
one
we show that in this case when n
approaches infinity the fraction of
matched participants comes from this
formula
the proof of this is not too complicated
but it won't get through that
in the spot instead i want to draw your
attention to something more important
which is
the shape of this function
okay so here on the x-axis we have k the
number of applications
and the y-axis is the matching size or
fraction of mesh
agents so as you see with one
application around 63 percent
of the participants are matched it
increases with two applications and
three
applications to around 68 but after that
with more applications the matching size
decreases
and this is actually the first
interesting fact that we observe in this
case
um so based on the formula we know that
the matching size is not monotone in the
number of the applications but
intuitively what is the main reason
we realized that having more
applications has
both a positive and a negative effect
the positive effect is that with more
applications
the number of positions that receive any
application increases
for example with one application only 60
63 percent of positions
receive any applications as you see it
goes up pretty quickly with more
applications
but the negative effect is that um since
the
applicants are applying to multiple
applications
the probability that an accepted
application belongs to
some applicant who has other accepted
application increases
so this leaves some of the agents with
more
than one offers while the rest received
no offer
so in this picture we see that after we
increase the number of applications from
three
the negative effect takes over and we
have a decreasing cure
okay so we completely understand what
happens when the number of interviews is
one
and all the applicants are applying to
the same number of positions
but is there any hope of achieving this
larger matching
if we allow applicants to apply to
different number of positions
so first we show that given any average
number of applications x
it is best to let a group of people
apply to florex number of positions and
the rest apply to ceiling x
basically the larger size of matching
happens when either
all the applicants are applying to the
same number or they apply to two
consecutive
numbers based on this lemma we can
find the size of the matching also in
this case
again i won't go through the proof but
when i draw your attention to the shape
of
this new function that we have all right
so on the x-axis we have the average
number of applications by each applicant
and on the y-axis we have the size of
the matching
and for example if we are at point 1.5
it means that half of the applicants are
applying to
one position and the rest the other half
are applying to two positions
so here we see our second
interesting fact which is this u shape
between two integers meaning that the
local maxima of this figure happens when
all the applicants are applying to the
same number of positions
so i want to wrap up the case with a
single interview with two messages
the first one is that the optimal number
of applications
um is three no matter if we no matter
what distribution we choose to
distribute the applications
and the second one is that a first
system of
distribution gives the highest matching
size
which means that the local maxima of the
figure are the
integer points and more particularly for
example if we are here
if everybody is applying to two
positions
if we favor a group of people and let
them apply to
one more position or if we discriminate
against the group
and let them apply to one less position
the size of the matching
is going to decrease
i also want to quickly mention what
happens when we have multiple number of
interviews
so the formula and the
solution for this case is going to be
more complicated but at the end of the
day we are able to find the expected
matching size
with arbitrary k number of applications
and k prime number of positions
here um the x-axis is again the average
number of applications
and the y-axis is the size of the
matching here we see the cure with
a single interview that we saw
previously this is with two interviews
three interviews and so on so as you see
with more applications we still have
our two weird properties than
non-monotonicity
and also they u-shaped between integers
as before but it happens with a lesser
degree
i also want to quickly emphasize that
these weird behaviors
are consequences of limiting the number
of interviews if we don't have
any limits on the number of interviews
the matching side is going to be
monotonically
increasing and the number of
applications
okay let me conclude um our main
technical contributions are
one computing the expected size of the
matching as the outcome of the deferred
acceptance algorithm when there are
limits on the number of applications and
interviews
and two finding the optimal way of
distributing the applications
when we're given the total number of
applications
our work comes with two policy
recommendations the first one is that
if we have limited ability granting
interviews we may need to limit
the number of applications as well to
have a large matching
and the second one is that the optimal
matching size is achieved by a fair
system
that's all thank you for your attention
awesome thanks um so i think
let's go ahead with the last talk of the
session and then we can have the
discussion
afterwards so i think that's um
yes you want to start sharing your
slides okay
oops oh sorry
ah you see them no
uh it says your screen sharing but i
just see a
blank page this happens
a little bit uh it might help if you
instead of sharing the application just
share your entire desktop
no no well clean it up and then
give it a go uh
[Music]
can you see it now still no
okay uh
uh what happened here sorry
so now we do see your
desktop i think okay can you see the
slides now
i don't think that's what we're looking
at i think we see a browser
can you switch to your slides right
can you switch to your slides i i have
switched my screen is showing my
slides so our view of your screen looks
like it's showing a browser
of a youtube video okay that's
uh this one okay i will just
purge it and uh and i will start
share screen and uh
and uh and and
and here this is what i want to share ah
good excellent
i ah now you should have it now we see
it
good okay so uh
welcome everybody to this talk uh and
uh i hope you can hear me uh this is
joint work with
mihaly fianna kakis and
what it is about is uh is the
computational complexity of this uh
fabulous scheme of philanthropy causer
to economist
from harvard actually zak hauser was the
was the advisor
of hailand who was a student at harvard
zakhauser is still at harvard healing is
somewhere in scandinavia
uh and zach hauser is a very
important economist uh okay and this is
for one sided matching market so
i know this is a very diverse crowd so
let me uh
just say what a matching market is uh
so these are different from commodity
markets
um in that say for instance uh college
admission is a matching market
uh and uh the
interesting thing to see here is that a
student cannot buy admission to ucr
wine no matter what she's willing to pay
she also needs to be chosen
uh that's talking about ucr wine at usc
some people have
bought admission some rich and famous
people bought admissions for their
daughters
and then they had to go to jail um
okay so so um so that's what this is
this market is about
it's a market in which you cannot simply
choose what you want
you also have to be chosen and typically
there's no
exchange of money involved
[Music]
so the big question is why is this even
a market
as we know markets and the reason
that actually al roth gave me
was that uh because it aggregates
information held by
the participants which is what markets
do that's why these things are called
markets
and by now there are lots of markets
from all walks of life
and the best way i know how to classify
them is through revolutions in computer
science
um the first one was of course the gail
stapley stable matching market
uh stable matching paper which led to
the matching of residents to hospitals
and
in the pre so so this is a very ancient
field in that sense
matching students to schools uh kidney
exchange and so on
and then what happened was these
computer science revolutions of the
internet which
gave rise to the adwords market which uh
almost entirely funds uh google's
massive
expenses their uh their free
uh uh search uh
gmail uh uh youtube everything
upwork which matches uh uh workers to uh
to jobs uh mechanical turk is similar
match.com does the traditional matching
of uh men and women
and then came mobile computing which led
to even more interesting matching
markets more interesting or not but more
managing markets newer matching markets
uber and lyft airbnb
and uh there's one more matching market
that's really relevant to all of us
which is not in this because it's not
really
mechanized like these ones and that is
the academic job market
where every hire is a one-off and you
cannot really uh
automate this process okay so but but
that
the fact that the job market has been a
market in everybody's minds to tell you
that
this is not uh an anomaly to call it a a
market
these kinds of things okay so
so uh so this general and very powerful
uh
algorithmic tool uh okay so so so here
you can see that
on the one hand the field is ancient on
the other hand it's in its infancy
because with these new
revolutions you certainly gave rise to
very very interesting very very
uh impactful markets which are occupying
a bigger and bigger fraction of the
economy this is only a small
sampling of these so what we need really
is
these kinds of general tools because if
there's a new market tomorrow you want
to
take one of these tools uh and off the
shelf
you know just plug in a mechanism to
start running it
instead of devicing yet another uh
algorithm for it
and this goes back to 1979 he landed in
sickhauser
and they used the power of a pricing
mechanism to
run a one-sided matching market now
uh what's the pricing mechanism where
you you basically
uh find prices through demand and supply
and that's
you try to make a parity between demand
and supply and that gives rise to
many many nice properties uh has always
been
the central uh tenet in economics
uh it avoids artificial scarcity has led
to efficiency has
created massive wealth in the west and
so on and so forth
uh so so how exactly it comes about will
be
the next slide but what's the one-sided
matching market
so you saw two-sided matching markets uh
in the last few talks
uh one-sided is where only one side has
preferences unless unlike say
uh say uh the boy girl markets where
boys and girls both have
men and women both have uh have uh
have preferences so like agents and
goods goods are done they don't have
preferences
okay uh and i just want to say that
that the econo uh hill and zeke houser
scheme
uh seems like a novelty in uh
theory and theoretical computer science
in another theory namely
economic theory it's a classic uh and we
and so there's a new book coming out on
matching markets uh this healing the
causer will be in the very introductory
chapter of that
so um so you can view this
uh market as a marriage between linear
fisher market which really is a market
with money and
goods and and goes about finding
equilibria
and and is run through the pricing
mechanism
and perfect matching okay so
think of the market as having n agents
and indivisible goods
and each agent has told us
her utility for all the goods uij for
good j
that's for agent i and we want to find a
perfect matching of agents and goods
for that the allocation is pareto
optimal
which means that the only way to improve
any one agent's
allocation is to diminish another one's
agent uh allocation so it's sort of
maximally good
and yeah of course if you give uh uh
okay
yeah there are trivial solutions support
optimality but uh
but you it's also envy free and all that
so so that's so that you don't
uh uh boil down to some trivial solution
like uh
in this case you cannot do that but if
you give all the goods to one agent
you'd say oh it's pareto optimal of
course it's pretty optimal that but
that's uh
that's not what we're looking for anyway
uh
it's also incentive compatible in the
large so if you have lots of agents
no no one person can can cheat and
all these these two properties really
come about from the fact that we are
running it through
supply and demand uh like a pricing
mechanism
and so let's talk about that so
so in order to really be a fisher market
goods have to become
divisible and that's done by making each
good be one unit of probability shares
and you assume that each agent has one
dollar
uh of money uh this is fake money
it's no novelty today but in 1979 this
was a big concept
to have fake money uh and
each good jay has a price non-negative
okay and the allocation now
will be one unit of probability shares
to each agent
so that the entire allocation is a
fractional perfect matching
because you will have at each buyer the
x i j is adding up to exactly one at
each good also the
exergy is adding up to exactly one and
these are fractions these are
probability shares
so each good is one unit of property
probability share each buyer gets one
unit of probability share
so you need to find such a fractional
perfect matching
through some this pricing mechanism
and so going further uh we define the
notion of an equilibrium so given
price is p so and and
an allocation so always think of an
allocation as a fractional perfect
matching so prices and allocation are in
equilibrium
if every agent gets a utility maximizing
bundle of goods
so every agent solves this linear
program subject to the fact of course
that
x is a is a fractional perfect matching
okay and one small uh point to be
mentioned
which is what leads to pareto optimality
is that
uh so notice that an agent need not
spend her entire dollar
she may be able to her utility utility
maximizing bundle may cost zero dollars
for all we know
so that's what she'll get uh but if
there are several of these
that cost less than one dollar and our
utility maximizing then she should get
the minimum cost
and only then we can prove that the
entire allocation is uh
pareto optimal this is a very subtle
point but very key to
make sure that pareto optimality holds
for the entire allocation
and you if you have
worked on equilibria you always have to
put in the condition that the market
clears
but that's guaranteed if x is a
fractional perfect matching of course
all goods are sold because every good is
one unit of property shares and it's all
sold
by definition of fractional perfect
matching
and once you get this fractional perfect
matching you
apply a break of one diamond theorem to
round it up to
an integral perfect matching and that
will also be part optimal
that's very easy to see okay and the
point is uh it is a very non-trivial
but not very but quite a non-trivial
proof there are more non-trivial proofs
around this fact uh that equilibrium
exists and it uses the fixed point
theorem
which of course is highly
non-constructive so the question of
efficient computability is
is front and center and somehow it has
not been addressed in our
community and
and the major hurdle here is that the
market does not satisfy weak gross
substitutability what is that
that says that if you increase the price
of one good
the demand of another good cannot come
down
okay it should not uh normally if you
increase the price of one good
then other goods look better and their
demand should only go up yeah
you have a question matt um i was just
giving you a heads up that uh time is
out so if you can try and wrap up in a
minute or so
lord i haven't even started okay
okay so so you you don't have okay so
anyway for the zero one case we can
give a polynomial time algorithm uh it
goes also for
by uh okay and and here's a an example
with irrational uh
equilibrium four agents for goods and
the amazing thing is that
this example satisfies the all these
equations which would tell you that
it's rational because at each buyer each
good and each agent spends
exactly one dollar how on earth are
these irrationals adding up to ones
everywhere
okay the consequences that it's not in
ppid
and we show that it's in fixed p by
giving another proof of
existence of equilibrium using browser
6.0
and fxp is much much harder than ppid
probably
uh of course we have to show p naught
equal to np to make that probably go
away
and approximate equilibrium is uh
in ppid where uh notion of approximation
is uh
appropriate to this uh proof and the
proof is
uh to change the other proof a little
bit
and how do you get hardness results how
do you efficiently compute equilibria
approximate equilibria what do you do
about three valued utilities because for
two valued it's
a rational nnp four valued irrational
three valued we don't know
and there are many many generalizations
waiting to be handled like two-sided
matching markets
in this framework but nobody wants to go
anywhere near because
nothing can be even done about a
one-sided matching market
and if i have only one more second then
i'll just leave you with this very
important number
thank you all right thank you um
so we'll um we'll transition to the uh
discussion part of the session now
um so what we can start with is if
anyone has any
questions from the audience they'd like
to ask to any of the
speakers um i think
uh uh someone can correct me for wrong i
think it's okay if you're in
if you're a panelist already and you
want to just unmute yourself and ask
that that's okay
um
and maybe nobody has a question i just
want to ask
somebody if they have guessed what 132
is
i think we need your help that's the sum
of the edges of the two authors
um so it looks like there was someone in
the audience who raised their hands
i think i didn't it looked uh
let me see i think you can talk now
uh yep can you uh hear me yes
ah cool so uh i had a query
with respect to the uh on the last
author's
presentation so uh uh what's the
uh uh empirical uh evidence that you
have
uh uh supporting your
uh complexity uh i mean because it's
a one-sided matching market
so uh i was thinking more in terms of
the
implementational uh the
empirical implementation and what
what was the uh data structures that you
used if if i need to no no no
no we don't know that it's hard yet no
we haven't proven
hardness results okay it just
it just okay i i don't know i don't want
to take a crack at that kind of a
question without solid evidence
uh but we really uh
i mean all these years went into trying
that
okay okay yeah because the um
theoretical bounds look good but yeah uh
empirically there's no theoretical
boundary we're just saying that it's
fixed
it lies in fixed p and fixed is is
fixed the company problems are likely to
be very close to p space complete
problems
not not close to p so
the theoretical results are not pointing
to anything uh very
uh useful here
is when you have zero one utilities and
extended to
when everybody's utilities are too
valued by valued
everybody has two numbers and the all
the incredible trees come from those two
numbers
but the two numbers can be different for
different ages
as soon as we have three numbers we are
we raise our hands and we are
we are we cannot say anything about it
for four numbers we have uh
irrational example and that's the reason
that the problem is not even in ppad
because every problem in ppid has to
have rational solutions
and this this example has only an
irrational solution
and no rational solutions even though
all those equations that i showed you
must hold for a do-hole even in fact
even for that irrational
solution
thanks um vijay can you also turn off
your uh screen share
for the rest of the discussion oh oh
good good good good good i thought you
everybody wanted to stare at the
number a bit more okay
um so i have a few questions but people
in the audience should feel free to
interrupt me with questions of their own
too
um so can i get back um to clay so
in your model you said that all the
results held
when each tier constituted a fixed
fraction
of the market and i'm wondering
how sensitive the results are to that
assumption or if some sense of them
would hold if everyone had an individual
score or what would you expect those
results to look like instead
so the in that respect the tiers are
mostly for
like cleanness and convenience the
key results that it's proportional to
your public score
would actually still hold um but we
couldn't write down
what those ranks would actually be
got it thanks um and then i had
a um a question for hedya too
um so at the end of your
talk you uh mentioned some policy
implications for the
work and i was just wondering um
is maybe an open-ended question but i
guess sort of like how literally would
you
take those recommendations or if you
wouldn't take them super literally what
is the
like what's the next step that you would
want to see in this line of research
right so um the assumption that the
distributions come from uniform
distribution
is essential for our results but
it's mainly essential because of the
technical reasons so like we can only
calculate
calculate our findings when the
distributions are uniform
so it depends on how much still
the same weird behaviors hold with
non-uniform distributions
so i think like maybe that's the first
step to make the model
more realistic but i just want to
mention that we
kind of understand the study the role of
the randomness
and there are other papers that study
kind of the extreme case when
the preferences are almost identical or
very correlated
so in that case the congestion is
mainly like the non-monetized mononone
ethnicity or the congestion it's mainly
because of
popular agents and here we get the
opposite case
so it depends on how much when we look
at the models in between the things hold
sorry are you saying like the findings
reverse in the really correlated model
um if you get the congestion for it's
mainly because for example let's say
that some
people are much more popular than the
rest yeah
so it's they will get like a lot of
offers
right so like in that case it's not too
um
surprising to see that with more
applications your matching site might
decrease
right um and then i have maybe one
follow-up question that's maybe
appropriate
for either hedera or clay so i guess
clay's paper
involved a model that was kind of like
barely beyond uniform
do you have any sense of if someone were
to push in the next direction if you
were to pick maybe one side of the
market
to be drawn from a model more like the
one from clay's paper
is your intuition that that still
immediately becomes intractable
or do you think there's hope there's
hope of that maybe being a good
direction and which side of the market
that sounds like a great direction to me
because it's
as also clay mentioned it's maybe the
first step to go beyond uniform
distribution
um i should think more of like which
side of the market to be tiered
maybe clay has some ideas
um for our paper putting the proposing
side in tiers was much harder
um but it might depend
on the exact model
the the fact that the like non-sorting
fact that we got
we sort of interpreted it that you need
something stronger or different than our
model to
for example tell people who they should
interview
since the the real stable matching in
our model
doesn't tell you who should match to who
with any significant predictive power
maybe you would need something like uh
polynomial gaps in scores
all right and i think there's uh one
more paper specific question
from aviyad that's written down so i'll
just read it out loud is uh vijay can
you
elaborate on what you meant by an
extension to two-sided matching
oh yeah so so suppose that you have two
sides uh so these are not
agents and goods goods being done but
let's say
agents and employers
okay workers and employers and each side
has preferences for the other side
given not through a preference list like
in
in gel shapely but given through
utilities
uijs and wijs okay
and now you know you can extend
the definitions to get a notion of
equilibrium
and so on and so forth um does it exist
what's the uh what are algorithmic
results there
what are irrationality results there
more importantly because those will be
many many more probably
my guess is even zero one is uh
irrational so i played around with it
quite a bit
uh without getting any positive results
um and there are so i i've been in touch
with zack hauser and
the very first time i sent him an email
he sent me this longer list of models
that he wanted to attack
and and and
i told him look we cannot even do the
basic model how can we go any further so
but but
so the point is that you can you can
think of many many interesting models
and he said this is interesting and this
is interesting and this is interesting
yeah they are interesting but uh but
what can we do so
so we are waiting really for uh for some
positive news on maybe approximate
equilibria or something else
uh before we can head to all those
models and and i think i think
the economists and maybe even the
applications uh
uh people would like like them once they
they
get found and worked out
but good question navier uh let's do it
uh
next fall together
do you think approximation is doable
[Music]
which is the main stumbling block for
exact computation
comes up very strongly in approximate
also
sometimes one can get around around
wheat cross substitutability
people have some results like that but
in this case it's quite severe
um so uh
i i have some other ideas maybe if they
pan out by
february march i you you i will i will
share them with you through some forum
or the other
thank you cool
but but please be mindful
of the age of the authors because the
younger people have to take over the
mantle now
well um i just want to give a quick
heads up to everyone that it's uh
almost um to uh 11 30 and the
next session is going to start in room b
um there's still another
question so we'll take the question and
we'll keep talking um but if you were
hoping to go to the next session
that was just a this is your warning
that it's going to start soon
um so there was a question for clay
in the chat um i'll just read it out
loud
uh for the recording um do you have any
thought about how to check empirically
your result that every pair of agents
has the same probability of being
matched property
so we've checked it with simulations or
rather gung has checked it with
some great simulations and although the
convergence is really slow it does go to
uniform
in constant tiers in real life i don't
know
if we could find markets that
satisfied these assumptions really well
uh preferences are really correlated
uh you know even if the gap
is pretty big between say harvard and
cambridge community college um
a constant score gap would predict that
one percent of people would rank the
community college above harvard
um so i would say that this points
in the direction that this indicates
that you
yeah you need stronger assumptions to
get the sorting that we see
in real world markets
nice um so i had uh
only prepared kind of like one more
general question
myself so i'll just ask but uh speakers
you should feel free to just
ignore it and drop off if you're done so
i was curious if um
the speakers or any of the co-authors
who are panelists who wanted to share
um if you wanted to share maybe is more
relevant for the students in the
audience
what was like the most exciting paper
in the research area relevant to what
you just presented
that kind of like got you really hyped
to work in this area
um or that got you excited to start
whatever project you just presented
or it could be a series of papers or or
something
and i guess we can go in we can go in
any order
and the co-authors who are visible can
share too
so for me i think it was actually matt
when you told me about
the ashlagi konoria leshno result that
with uh just say n
men and n minus one women the advantage
of being the proposing side
is basically completely neutralized and
it's better to be
a woman because you you just have that
one fewer agent and imbalance is really
powerful
uh so maybe i can go next so for the for
for this literature of online online
matching so i think the most
so the most important inspired piper for
me is the kiwi waste paper in 90s
which introduced this small this is very
fundamental model
and so later in the djk sorting paper
he introduces a classic framework of
primary
analysis to analyze this competitive
ratio and
even in the recent study for more
complicated model
they also try to adapt this chromosomal
analysis
and i think those are all very great
paper
uh can i add a comment to your uh
thoughts
yes so uh uh following up on the primal
dual analysis there was a
exactly based on that really uh taking
all their ideas
there was a paper of uh and nicole
feldman and
hemosphere and some other people giving
an economics based analysis
and and that's
particularly clean and these two are
really for the first time textbooks
textbook quality uh
analysis because kbb was never in a
textbook
and as i mentioned there's a book on
matching markets
in one of the fundamental chapter
results chapter there'll be a
an exposition of kvb it'll be on my
website as soon as i put it there
that chapter and you can see the the the
very
very very clean analysis so beautiful uh
coming from these two papers it's
finally you can teach it
i believe even to undergrads certainly
to graduate students
i'll put it on my web page uh i promise
today is what wednesday certainly by
next monday you will you will see it on
on my webpage
nice and um for those of you following
in the chat there's um
also some references to the papers that
just got mentioned
yeah talk at sosa this week yeah that's
that's that kira just mentioned that the
the mikhail film and natal paper will be
in sosa
yeah alone eden also yes and uh
and uh i believe atmosphere and maybe
there's one more author i i forget
yeah cannot remember everything anymore
all right i guess um if no one else
wants to
share we can end the session i guess
hedja do you have anything you want to
share
sure for me it was um a more lika
mathian paper from 2005
that got me interested in this whole
matching market with shortlist
and um they're actually like interesting
solutions
that's quite interesting for me
nice okay um so maybe we can
um end the session
but i think a lot of the authors um
mentioned that they're happy to follow
up um
offline and we'll see you all back in
gather
thanks for joining